could you firstly explain the term IA
and could you also as uh by way of
confirming for the Muslims out there
whether they should be doing this or not
um is it compulsory for all Muslims to
do it
alhamd
the
word is derived from the Arabic rude
word which means to adhere to cling to
stick it means to
keep and it means to engage or devote
something to another
thing which may be good or
bad and it's mentioned in the Quran in
Surah Ambia chapter number 21 verse
number 52 when Abraham Alam he speaks to
his father and to his people saying that
the images which you
devote those who do idol worship Etc
he's telling that the image which you
devote and the word
used which you so devot attached to
which are clinging to it here it's used
in the wrong sense in the negative sense
there are also vers in the Quran which
speak in the positive sense in Sur Bak 2
vers 125 Bak ch vers 187 according to
Lan Arab the word EA means to fully
attach oneself to
something it means when someone habitat
the mosque and he worships in it in the
Islamic Sharia the word EA means to
engage and retreat in the mosque and to
stay in the mosque seeking nearness to
Allah tala and seeking his
reward as far as the ruling of EA is
concerned whether it's compulsory or it
a
Sunnah is generally a
Sunnah it's not compulsory it only
becomes compulsory in certain cases if
someone makes a vow to Allah subhana
tala that he will do if his wish is
fulfilled for example someone will say
that I will DOA for two days if my SI
relative is cured
or I going do for 3 days if I pass in
the examination so if someone vows to
Allah subhana wa ta'ala for the
Fulfillment of his desire then EA is
compulsory whatever the person has vowed
he has to fulfill it otherwise EA is the
Sunnah but it is a a very highly
recommended
Sunnah as it's mentioned in the
Hadith of bukari volume number eight in
the book of of Oaths and vows Hadith
number
6696 where the messenger of Allah subh
said that anyone who
promises to obey Allah subhana wa ta'ala
he should obey him and anyone who
promises Disobedience to Allah subhana
wa taala he should not disobey
him and
there with him mentioned bukari volume
number eight
in the book of Oaths and Wows Hadith
number
6697 where with him he says to the
messenger of Allah subhana tala that I
had vowed in the days of ignorance
before he embraced Islam that he will do
for one night in mid Haram so the
prophet said that fulfill your wow
because the wow was good OB being Allah
subhana prophets is
fulfilled and there are various verses
in the Quran we speak abouta
Allah says in Surah Bak chapter number
two verse number 125 he tells to ibraim
Alam and Isam that oh ibraim and is May
peace be upon them you
sanctify the C of Allah subhana tala the
house of Allah subhana taala because
people circum ulate around the Caba and
they stay they DOA they retreat in the
mosque and some of the Believers they
bow and they prostrate while worshiping
Allah subhana tala here the word EA
Retreat is used it's further mentioned
in Surah Bak chapter number 2 verse
number 187 that do not associate with
your wives when you retreat in the
mosque when you do in the mosque and
there are sever talking
about including sayari volume number
three in the book of Hadith number
2026 AA pleas with her who the wife of
the Prophet she said
that the prophet used to DOA for the
last 10 days in the month of
Ramadan and after he died the wife of
the Prophet used to continue their
practice so e unless vowed its compc
otherwise generally it's a Sunnah but
highly recommended Sunnah well I'm
rather glad that you of course have
confirmed that it is a sun otherwise I
would have had to have gone back for 16
years and repeated my Ramadan in the
last 10 days well doct in after hearing
the goodness of and inshah you start
doing it in your life inshah may Allah
make it easy for all of us indeed to
perform